hello everyone I hope you can hear me
thank you for having me it's such an
honor to be here and I really think how
cool is to be a student at Stanford I
wish to be sitting with you as your
peers but I'm on stage and I think this
is a distinct thing second best position
so we'll we'll talk today about my
career path and the reason why I will
share with you even more information
that you can find on googling about
myself is because I really believe in
young generation and I believe that when
I was a student listening true story and
real story was very helpful and you are
envisioning your future
and you're shaping your future is
Stanford and so Stanford and most
importantly beyond that so I'll tell you
my story and hopefully you will find
some inside for shaping even more your
future let's start with my title
envisioning the non-obvious well I was
born and raised in a little country
village near Rome and today I am the CEO
of a publicly-traded company in America
living in New York
how non-obvious was that and is that
considering when I was a student like
you I could not possibly imagine
I heard one things though that I knew
probably what I consider at that time
the final goal and today I feel too
young to think that it's it's it's the
end and it's final which is becoming a
CEO I really wanted to do that so I knew
the final goal but I didn't know how to
get to there and what I did was to start
by choosing a fine
work for my university the TASIS in the
fastest growing industry at that time
which was the mobile phone no one had a
mobile phone very few people can you
imagine your life without mobile phone I
leave that and I was young as you as you
are today and I needed to to choose
something that was helping me to then
find a job especially in the Italian
market where it's not easy for the young
generation to fight to find a job so I
thought that that one was already
envisioning the future studying
companies that were making lots of money
by building networks on the buildings
themselves to create the network the
coverage for for the mobile phones so
there were company that we're selling
the phones and company that were selling
the the network so I approached that
that stallion
thanks to that stasis I could enter in
the telecommunication field and when I
was interviewed by Samsung they wanted
to hire someone who could know more and
better the the telecommunication war
that was a very young younger at that
time but because of my TASIS I could get
the job so I was working for a Korean
boss who taught me a lot most
importantly to not get too stressed by
the work that I needed to do but to work
more and to face the threat to stress by
working more and after I left the
telecommunication field by joining the
fashion world
can you imagine after over five years of
telecommunication consumer market how
was called that time going into the
luxury world so I was perceived
an alien by my colleague and even if I
had a very strong sense of side still I
needed to beat all the older prejudice
so as much as Samsung I needed to
over-deliver and learn first and make my
interest of fashion a professional
know-how
so I started by buying all the books
about about fashion about who make the
difference about the brand's and
learning globally the fashion because it
was a head of global and that was an
important moment for me and experience
to get international to travel to travel
the work so working themes list with the
Japanese with Middle Eastern with the
European and the Americans of course and
after that I joined Ferrari again
another big change in different way
professionally and personally of course
professionally I needed to create
collection inspired by the cars and as
much as I loved Ferrari I really didn't
know anything about his work cards and
so it was another learning curve for my
life to learn a lot a lot but that kind
of mindset helped me to then face the
first approach to America when I was
called to come and run the the American
operations for Dolce & Gabbana and again
at Lands End so now even if for most of
the people seems a big change for me
it's like my Karma my path my career
path is to always envisioning the
non-obvious and making changes and
embracing changes if we can start from
from the slides
I would like to share with you the
guiding principles that are used in
amusing in in in the company to lead
this company iconic company into a
meaningful global lifestyle brand so my
my five guiding principle are the
360-degree mindset and I will explain
you why in a second so as I was saying
it is important to know where you're
going to land in my case as I say to you
I wanted to become a CEO and I always
thought that by knowing where you want
to go you can then define your life in
different chapters and trying to learn I
was having a starving curiosity and
trying to learn not just the business
which was my number one interest of
course but I wanted to know about art
about architecture about music about
literature about politics about history
and that mindset really helped me also
to start learning other languages my
English is not perfect but as I was
saying I speak four languages and having
that mindset helped me in the company
today so to give you a pragmatical
example we are now conceiving and I
encourage the company to conceive the
project with a 360-degree mindset one to
approach it as we are global we have
operation in Japan in UK and in Germany
by the word they speak and we can be
even bigger so that figure of the world
will tell you what how much we can grow
and having this 360-degree mindset what
does it mean for us we created a
collection that is an additional
collection that we're going to launch
pretty soon March 16 is the day to wear
what you're seeing here is going to be
available for the customer we are
calling that the designer collection
which will be added to the current one
for our loyal customer and we conceived
that thinking that there are different
body shapes there are different
ethnicity you know we're here in San
Francisco at Stanford there are people
represented by different countries so
from America to the rest of the world
there is not just the American feet
which we have and make us stronger so we
can leverage on that but also add this
international fit so the 360 degree
helped me immediately to say this is
what we miss this is what we can do and
what we can bring at Lands End as well
and also doing campaign in acting as a
brand is very important because all the
project that in the presentation to that
to their collection was made in the
three main fashion capital so Tokyo
London and New York and we are now doing
in in using old touches point which are
the cattle of the website as I told you
before the social media to present
ourselves in a more global way so
360-degree I can I can actually take
that so will be easier thank you so as I
was saying also doing pop-up stores they
helped us as we did it for example for
the holidays that helped us to grow the
awareness of this new additional
collection the second principle that is
probably one of my
August 1 is the excellence surpass
perfection there are leaders that choose
perfection as their setting the bar for
the organization and when you do that
what you can risk to create is a
cultural of fears the fears to fail
while what I actually like more is the
possibility to fear and the
experimentation so while you can
experiment you can of course you have to
be able and to accept failure the most
important thing is how fast you can
react and how quickly you can fix
something to make sure that then
everything going going well but of
course nobody wants to fail
we don't conceive things in that way
what we want to do is to raise the bar
and making sure that we do everything
possible to get to strive for perfection
but to reach excellence excellence is
good enough it gives a sense of opposite
optimises into the organization and it
is very important and we I can tell you
that we applied that principle in two
main element one is the catalog so as a
as I was saying we have a loyal customer
that we wanted to continue the light and
we wanted to also conquer new consumers
so we needed to have new catalogs and we
needed to delight both customer the
catalog that we had were definitely
beautiful and if we weren't thinking to
just continue doing what we're doing
without any experiment and without
trying different things we couldn't
reach at the excellent catalog that we
have today before coming here I think
you just complimented me
on the catalog that you saw and the
advancement that we did is that perfect
not yet we will get there but you will
get there step by step and again
experimenting every time same things for
the website on the website as I was
saying to you we are launching on March
16 a new section for launching this
collection and it doesn't mean that for
this year everything we've done is not
perfect everything we have done in this
year is too great step by step
increasing operational way to make sure
that your online experience is better
you can shop faster and you are pleased
with the navigation so we created the
new index or an Express Checkout so we
are adding things little by little and
what we are creating now it's a new
creative content that can speak
different languages because even the
visual language is different for each
eyes we have different taste so
different people wants to see visually
different things so that's what we're
trying to do but again if I was thinking
what is the perfection only I could not
reach that immediately so I sit with my
team and defining what we're the set and
how fast we can move into what we
consider the excellence and hopefully
our consumer will continue to be
delighted and as I said the research of
excellence is a constant journey
everything is a constant journey but the
research of that is even more so you
cannot think that you finish the moment
you have you have done a great job this
is
starting point for a new moment for real
facing the competition that is fierce
especially online where everybody today
can just start a company online and so
you have even more competition that you
used to have so we need to be very
strong and continue as I would say
experimenting feel but then can
immediately react and we're not perfect
but definitely I think that this
organization is excellent the other
principle which was really linked on my
personal story is the changing and adapt
if you embrace changes you can grow much
more and much faster then and it's
easier to say than to leave I really
would like for you to think for a moment
that I was surrounded by clothes and
shoes and the next month next day it was
surrounded by cars and wonderful people
technician they were all dressed in red
the families were very welcome while in
the fashion work is is a bit different
my son was able to touch the Formula One
car so it was an amazing experience to
to go into Ferrari but as I was saying
changing our changes can be scaring but
if you use the Brack mindset that
changes can be just an opportunity for
you to learn more and to grow this is
the biggest opportunity that you can
have in your life of course you need to
be brave because the moment a
opportunity is presented to you they're
required to change what you're doing
it is it
scaring but if you face it with the
positive approach I'll keep learning
because you will never stop learning
your student now and when I was joking
to you before and say I would like to
see it with you I actually feel that I
am seething with you still because this
is what we keep doing I'm saying to my
son I hope you will choose something
that you like to do because you will
study your whole life and this is what
we do in the organization where I'm
working today I'm also encouraging this
idea of continued to adapt and and
change changes again are scaring but if
we do it adapting day by day on the new
opportunities that are in the market and
we research first of all who are our
competitors how we can face that and we
know that we need to be definitely able
to delight our colloidal customer in our
case so we needed to develop product
that were not the transecting design
that I used to make when I was two
working for Dolce & Gabbana I needed to
delight my loyal customer that have a
much more traditional approach so I
could show to my to my team that is
something we can I can do so everybody
can actually be adaptable and the
adaptability is the number one element
for always being ahead of the curve and
create success and the same things I did
for the modern collection so the motor
collection and I'm actually wearing a
piece of it is a collection that has
much more design aesthetic an
aspirational factor but it's not
as expensive as I was producing before
when I was in the luxury world so
adapting in this world also mean that we
can produce things in a different way
yes with a developer collection in in
Italy because as I was saying the body
shapes has to be in an international one
for this part of the collection and but
we produce the clothes in Asia so we
maintained the most important promise to
our customer which is the fair value
price so you will find this collection
very appealing but also very affordable
and this is something to show that we I
can be adaptable I could do that and of
course I knew that I could know that
that's why I also joined this company
but for most of the people that were
they were questioning if I could be able
to speak the language of the loyal
customer and while are conquering new
customer not to raise the bar too much
and alienate our customer this is not
our intent our intent is in my personal
intent is to maintain definitely what is
the DNA of the company leveraging on our
platform and conquering new consumers so
what we call the new customer
acquisition another important way for
saying that we are able to be adaptable
is that as I said the vision of this
company is to elevate the company into a
meaningful global lifestyle brand and so
we needed to act as a brand and acting
as a brand we made a project where
everybody rallied together from the
designing team the merchandising team
the supply chain the outfit business
Outfitters and we created and of course
the sales because then this backpack was
sold in
thus oriental online we created a
backpacker with a designer who won the
Project Runway Junior so we work with a
complete different project where we
never worked before and my team I wasn't
te talking with the designer who won is
a very young talented girl and the
challenge in that episode was launched
by the first lady who is on the on the
challenge to help girls around the world
out of education so the proceeded part
of the proceed for that backpack were
going to the Peace Corp 4-legger learns
project and this was an example on how
the company could really act as a brand
we radio together and that was another
moment where we could show that we can
change and adapt versus what we want to
to become another important guideline is
definitely exercising skills and in
particular new skill we are all born
with an aptitude and we have certain
skills that are our strengths those
skills are the one that you want to
leverage and you want to get stronger
from that skills but at the same time
you need to recognize your weakness the
moment you start to recognize the
weakness and and exercise what you don't
have in your strength is the moment that
really you can grow more so I can tell
you that this was one of the things that
I always tried to do personally and
professionally going to two lanes and
when I started I needed Li recognise
that they wear
a few few skills that this company maybe
had but did not even realize that they
had because they never exercised that
one was being nimble and so gather a
bigger sense of speed so we had a
project and the project was to open in
only six weeks which is a record for our
industry a huge store flagship store in
New York Fifth Avenue so we work in face
facing the world with that store we
could incredibly fail but instead we
succeed to open a pop-up store which was
a huge success not just for the fact
that the customer loved that that that
store the most importantly our
organization got a sense of positiveness
by knowing that yes they could have the
art nimble and they are fast they could
move so quickly than in six weeks for
whoever does this this business they
know it's really tough to build out a
store and to put the merchandise in
there to train to find the team to train
the team in 9,000 feet square feet so
there was one example another example of
being being nimble and exercise
different skills is definitely to find
efficiencies so when I joined the
company I saw also that we have a budget
that we spent in different activities
and this project could have been spent
in different way to gather also a bigger
brand awareness and higher brand
awareness so we started to look into the
different activities that we were doing
and say where can we find these
efficiencies and use our resources in
different way one was definitely the
store that I show you before other where
the brand spending so starting to have
campaign that a brand campaign that were
showing what we were doing one of the
latest activity we did and that's why we
had this this picture here was actually
in San Francisco talking about brand
activity for the Superbowl and we made
two distinct ting advertising campaign
one for the new customer and we needed
to conquer them and one for the lower
one we have a little video that we want
to show you
so this was the first video that we did
for the new customer that we wanted to
to conquer and so this customer is a
young customer definitely you didn't see
the the family around that customer as I
was saying to you we are seeking for a
new generation to come and and we are
developing product for them with a
different body shaper the most important
thing is that we were using the budget
that we had before not increasing the
budget actually we spent less last year
versus a year before by doing also
disorder activity we just allocate
differently the resources and this is
how we can say you can exercise skill
you can raise the bar you can do what
you probably didn't think we could have
done it so again another example for our
organization to show the muscle and to
to feel that they can be efficient and
create new things this is definitely
something different that for whoever
knows let's end already from the
previous one and in fact the other one
is another campaign that speaks more to
our loyal customer the loyal customer
that is today is definitely the school
uniform because we do serve oh not all
the school of America but almost and we
wanted to give a message of connection
to this consumer and of course the
families so this campaign had a
beautiful payoff we
in you and was gone by Bruce Weber so
again for the first time we were working
with a photographer that is a leader in
the industry and never work with lens
end but definitely have worked with
American strong company that were
rebuilt from all we're rebranded in the
past he worked for others that for sure
for sure you know very well we also have
a video here that I want to show to show
you the difference between what our
saying is a new customer and the loyal
customer that today represent the
biggest base for Lance and
today
hey let you pull - you gotta laugh a
little you got a car just a little you
gotta let those five skip by that's the
story
this is actually my sentiment to what I
can believe in the customer and I wanted
to tell them that we believe in you and
there was a loving message to them and
we showcased that video in areas that we
never image before to showcase Times
Square was the number one in the main
airlines of America so United virgin and
American Airlines so that was possible
again reducing the budget but still
doing this amazing activities because we
found efficiencies so exercising skills
the new skills the one that you don't
have I think it's the most important
thing for for your life was for me still
is for me keep learning and and that
will lead you into a greater success the
last one which which is also one of the
core principle that we have and then
send and one of the reason why I choose
to come and let's end is the leading
with purpose I could not conceive my
career only as a successful business
leader I would like to create something
that is also meaningful for for the
people for my customer for the future
generation so lends hand is a legacy for
doing this activity since the past the
founder Gary comer was in activist
environmental since the 70s he was
talking about global warming so we took
the sustainability and the corporate
social responsibility had a bigger and
higher stance and we decided to make
that as part of our of our program to
lead with purpose the one project that I
started to do going back to the slide is
the lens friendly we launched after 90
days that I was in England sent we
created the lens friendly which was
launched the day of a her day her day is
today a global movement on April 22nd
and was initiated in Wisconsin so while
searching because if you search and
young allies and you always create a new
project and we launched at that at that
point and our stand was create a better
environment so we sign an agreement a
greater agreement with National Forest
Foundation we had it before saying that
we were going to plant 1 million trees
and we wanted to reduce our carbon
footprint so reducing the distribution
of catalogs which are very loved by our
customer and we will continue to to
deliver to them but we made a research
and to understand what is the right
balance between sending the catalog or
having them shopping online and so
reducing and becoming a reducing the
carbon footprint and becoming more land
friendly so that was the first project
another project that we have today is
that we work with the University of
Wisconsin and we have for every semester
two or three project that are made by
student who will tell us which are the
others effort and that we can take for
the sustainability
and so this is something that we do with
them because we are close to to medicine
but as I was saying there is also a
project that we just did close to you on
the west coast which is the Alcatraz a
lighthouse why we support the lighthouse
we made an agreement with the US society
our society because the symbol of Lent
is a lighthouse and so because we have
the research of the study for
understanding what is needed to be done
to rebuild the the Alcatraz lighthouse
so we just made that that agreement in
last October 5th that we launched and
we're trying to continuously raise the
bar and making sure that we take care of
different stands that can be close to
all our customer so not just the one in
Wisconsin but also the one of the West
Coast and definitely nationally and more
importantly day by day globally and
internationally as we were saying so
this is the journey where I am today at
Lands End
by all the experiences that I did so far
is to make sure that I use all the skill
set that I learn in a different chapter
and day by day i continuous improve to
to create this global meaningful global
lifestyle brand I'm sure that one day
you will be leader in any industry that
you will choose to lead and I'm sure
that
you will choose different paths but the
one thing that I would like to see you
two to consider today from today on is
to embrace the non-obvious because the
non-obvious brought me in the end where
I am today and so as I share with you
the five principles that I had and I'm
still using in my professional career
what you have today is something that is
time time to learn in time to keep
understanding what will be the best for
you to keep learning and to improve your
skills to have a mindset that is a 360
degree to change and adapt and all I
said to you so far that embracing all of
that with an approach that everything is
possible you can do it and you can
become whoever you would like to become
if you have the final goal in mind it's
not necessarily that you need to know
right now but it's important that you
will shape that as soon as possible but
also that your final goal can be the
final go for one chapter and then you
can continue to increase your knowledge
and go to the next chopper and have
probably different different goals so I
wish you the best I would like to open
actually this session to questions
because I found it before in class that
those are the most interesting part for
all of you to understand better what
would you like to learn today thank you
oh okay so here we are looking at the
syringe full of all of these very unfair
minded folks who see you as an
incredible role model what do you wish
you had learned when you were in school
what would you do differently if you
could go back and sit in these chairs
what would you study what would you do
at that point because now I know it's
definitely to be more balanced and to be
patient it is important that you think
that everything should happen at that
moment and everything you want has to
happen the moment you think you want it
but instead you can get there but you
can get there by being by understanding
that the experience is also very
important you cannot just continuously
go and think that you can do something
but it's important that you got the
experience for that and sometimes you
get frustrated because you think that
you know already it's not really true
somebody over you knows that you need to
learn something more before to move to
the next steps
so be patient and understand that the
balance between what you think to know
and what is your personal role evolution
not just the professional evolution is
very important that will lead you into
the next chapter of of your life with
regard sheer marketing campaigns like
the advance friendly how do you decide
which direction to take with your
marketing because it seems pretty pretty
focused uh it was an easy one to choose
because as I said I research and see
that in our DNA
already had a lot of legacy for being
lens friendly we never used the name and
because I come from a marketing
background so I created the name with my
team that actually better the name and
we're very pleased and so that was the
first the first reason the second reason
is because for our name our name is LAN
cent who needs to take care of the land
and where the land said if not us so
there were two two elements and actually
the name inspired me the names make me
come to LAN sense because the moment I
hear the name I amazing where the lands
and there are many places in the world
and this is where all of us I think I
would like that one day lengths and is a
state of mind where you can get your ex
escape but of course it's all connected
to the environment so that's why for me
was kind of anything to go are there any
is there any to use to decide whether
that feels right or uh I was saying
previously to the other class that when
you have a project that you want to do
especially this kind of project that can
be very tricky any kind of meaningful
initiatives if you're not authentic
people will not understand that and will
not follow you so the metrics that we
use is the authenticity is that a real
part of the DNA of the company or we're
stretching too much and going outside
the path that we are creating so the
metric was how real we can look to our
customer if we choose the environment as
our initiative for for the meaningful
project so as I was saying our
founder mr. Gary comer was an
environmentalist activist so it was an
easy one we were already having an
agreement with the National Forest
Foundation but it wasn't that meaningful
and great to plant up to 1 million trees
so those were the were the elemental
this one was one of the campaign that
really resonate to to our consumer so we
were very pleased
so I she was first yes so she asked me
since I work in different industry how I
found those job basically and so the
first one as I was saying to you was a
choice by my Asus because I choose to
work in this industry and of course I
was looking for the job and I could find
something else about but in the
interview that I excelled the most was
at Samson when they interview me and
they knew that I know a lot about their
industries of my know-how my preparation
at the moment was the number one element
the the jump through the fashion was
actually a coincidence but first of all
I think I always had a very strong sense
of style I just simply did not conceive
that as a business and so when I I met
the designers in persons like for you
may think you know Moscow or all Steve
Jobs at that time for me was that mm
when I met the designers I I was brave
because I asked them what phone do you
use and they told me they were using
Motorola at that time I was in Ericsson
I presented the entire line of phones
for Ericsson and say you need to change
your mind because and I was explaining
to them what why Ericsson was a better
choice and so when they call me and they
wanted to have somebody that had that a
brave approach and of course they were
passing to be a more familiar company
versus a global company and I had
experience in global companies before
Eriksson like Samsung the different
processes and methods they wanted to
learn about that so I was expanding with
them the the operation internationally
but of course the being brave was
definitely the the element and for
Ferrari I was approached by a different
company in the same industry but I was
working for those Giovanna for so long
that I didn't feel to go work in another
fashion company I couldn't learn and to
me learning different things was the key
so I didn't move into that until I found
a company that was first of all global
and had an operation in New York because
my goal was to move to New York so once
I left and I went to to Ferrari the
designer really understood that I was
serious about New York I wanted to go
there so they approached me
just after to propose me to to go to New
York and coming back to the company
that's what I did and so that's that
what happened and expressing but now
it's the gentleman fredricka you are
translating on patience but as a public
company CEO Nicholas impatient investors
and you are scrutinized every quarter
and you are turning around a big ship I
wondered how what's your how do you
manage stakeholder expectations give
yourself time to so I said patient
imbalance and those two things are very
important so the patient is to really be
patient in moment aware it seems that
everything collapse because their
shareholders would like to have
something immediate but of course first
of all I have the sense of urgency
myself I don't need the design that the
the shareholder telling me to move
quickly because I try to really run
fast as I can to get results but at the
same time what my strength it was and is
is to build values to the brand into the
company so the value you will get more
and more on a long-term basis the short
performance is something that I also
would like to have of course for our
industry making new collection it
requires only time that you cannot
compress more than we already did so we
are launching this this new collection
the boat for the lower customer and the
new customer right now and it is one
year after I joined the company so by
the time you do that so this year can be
one year where you cannot really see the
results of my input and I should be
judged by them but I think they know
that they need to give you at least 18
months especially for big organization
like Lance and to turn things around
so of course if you can do it faster
it's even better but it's almost is
almost impossible I think that we are in
the right path to to change things
around but it's a constant journey to
keep improving and to the leader
performance what I did especially change
in different industry I needed to over
deliver and I learn and deliver there
was the most important thing to get to
the success so the people will call you
and say come to work and do this this
job so I proved that I needed to prove
it again and maybe because the result
was this free concept towards me that
helped me to give me another drive
besides the one that I have already
my DNA adaptability being an important
value how do you feel like you've had to
adapt to your management style and
yourself to the culture I had the
opportunity to have an experience in in
two companies that helped me very much
to be very close to exam one was the
Dolce Gabanna us working in u.s. already
knowing everything that is the new rules
the new procedures the new way the new
vacation time or you know the way you
say holidays or whatever is needed to
know it's it was very important that I
did it before so definitely that helped
me already a lot the other thing was the
word for variety in a such small little
country village near Modena
called Maranello which really looked
like Dodge Rio where I am when I go to
lanes and so by having those two
experiences and that's when I was saying
to you that all the skills that I
developed through the years are now
helping me to feel at home in lence and
first of all I really wanted to to have
this job this opportunity and by having
had the opportunity to work with the
American culture and to work with small
communities and coming from a small
community because my background was in
the country villages like I knew it
everybody so that was not impossible to
make that that a change and adaptability
but my sense of adaptability is stinking
to the future I always project myself 20
years after and not just myself but what
the consumer wants tomorrow what are
they doing what is already there that on
the cooking that we don't know today but
it's coming up and how can we close the
gap to make sure that we're not late so
that is my sense of adaptability
please join me in thanking our wonderful
guests today
you